this question comes from stan allister
this is a question i'm sure you've
gotten plenty of times and something
you've thought about yourself which is
there are many there are billions of
smartphones
why is it that there aren't clear videos
or clear photos
even though there are clear photos of
anomalous events let's say unexpected
events that are rare such as certain
meteorites
there's a few ways to answer that
question the first is that
he's absolutely right
there should be more images there should
be more videos taken
but
one of the things that
i was struck by when i started looking
at the claims that have been made and
i've also spoken to people in various
three-letter agencies about this
it is quite clear
that
the phenomenon is capable i think one of
the five observables that uh louis
lozando described was that the
phenomenon is capable of remotely
interfering with human technology
and robert salas for example describes
me the minuteman missile launch
commander from the 1960s described to me
how whatever the object was
it was able to manipulate remotely
the control systems for his icbm
missiles and shut them all down one by
one i've had conversations with people
in russia who've told me about similar
things in russia but it was even more
frighteningly the other way
all of a sudden their missiles went up
online and were rolled ready ready for
launch literally one button push from
launch
so something is capable of remotely
affecting the
human technology
i know that's mind-boggling and as a
hard-headed journal i find it incredible
that i'm having these conversations but
this is what the pentagon has been
advised this is the thing that i find
interesting is that a lot of the
skeptics and the debunkers have not yet
caught up with with all respect to them
the evidence that is being gathered to
show that the pentagon
uh
is aware of things that this phenomenon
can do that cannot be explained by known
technologies
and so
coming back to the question
a human camera i would have thought
operates electromagnetically it's quite
clear that there are aspects to the
phenomenon that are
fundamentally electromagnetic is it
remotely possible that they are capable
of meddling with our technology that
they're capable of
affecting our capacity to take good
photographs i'm struck kurt by the
number of times that i've spoken to
people who've witnessed the phenomenon
up close
and i've said to them why the hell
didn't you take a photo you know you
were there you had a bloody camera and
they go you know that's weird i it
didn't occur to me
that has happened time and time again
and it's interesting because uh there's
a series of incidents up around a place
called north west cape a very remote
military base in western australia
called the harold e holt naval
communications station which was an
american base until
1991 1992
and i've spoken to three people who've
witnessed the phenomenon in that part of
the world and each one of them describes
this kind of weird feeling where
they've actually forgotten about their
experience until in one case two years
later
nikolai the guy that i was talking to
was telling me that he'd seen an object
by the side of the road like a car
standing on its end a big solid
oval that was clearly metallic of some
kind but glowing emitting some kind of
plasma glow and he said he didn't even
remember it until two years after the
fact
so i keep on coming back to the fact
that one of the things that we just have
to acknowledge is that the pentagon is
being advised
the us department of defense is being
advised by the people who know
from the office of the under secretary
of defense intelligence probably louis
lozando and his team while they were
working on atip but also other people
i'm advised including the uap task force
they're being advised that whatever this
phenomenon is
it's psycho
psychometric
psychotronic psychotronic weaponry it
has the capacity to meddle with our
minds and to middle with our technology
so i i don't think it's entirely outside
the realm of possibility that
cameras are a bit of a doddle for
whatever it is to interfere with